Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik So, warte, erst mal Test auf, nach, eins, zwei, three. Mikrofon check, one, two!
Hey! Hey!
Hey!
Hey! I try not to think in movies, because every movie is in itself a whole lifetime. I only think in podcast episodes. Okay, but was, Mr. Herzog, what was your favorite podcast episode? My favorite podcast is from a child called the Tachipete. It's called Tichai Patu.
Tichai Patu, which I encountered in the jungle originally when I was shooting with Kinski at that time. How was Kinski at that time? When you get to know him, he is a very delicate person, but only when you know him. And when there was this time where he had those anger issues and he was shouting at everybody. Who was he shouting at? He was shouting at a call called the Taichalempa. No, it's the Taichalempu. And they only eat shadows. There are all their animals don't have shadows anymore because they ate it. Do they have an echo, those animals? Yes, they actually have twice as many echoes as normal children do. But when I was there, I still had my shadow and there came all those girls running around because they didn't know it a man with a shadow. Yes, but how did you lost, you specifically lost your shadow? I was trying to steal milk of a cow's udder and they caught me and as a punishment I had, they had to strip away my shadow. But where is it now? Where is your shadow at this very moment? I think it was sold to a tribe called the Tai-Chi-Lati. The Tai-Chi-Pum-Pu. Tai-Chi-Pum-Pu, it's a neighbor tribe and they only eat turkeys. But they have their shadows? They have my shadow in a little lunchbox. It's a Garfield lunchbox where it is stored to this day. Maybe I have lost it, because I have lost a Garfield lunchbox at that very time. I don't exactly know where it is at this moment. That could be very well, yes. How long can we do that? The thing with podcasts is it is a timeless medium.
The thing with the Werner Herzog impression is that it very much is sehr ermüdend. It is, it actually shows you the pain of your own existence, that with every day you move towards doom and have nothing to live for on this dry rock that we call our home, meine Damen und Herren, zum Podcast UFO, heute mit dabei stefan-hütze.de und stefan-wil.org. Wir freuen uns auf diese Folge. Wir sind glücklich, euch mitteilen zu können, dass wir bei Folge 75 angelangt sind. Das ist eine Zahl, wo ich persönlich sehr stolz drauf bin. Auf jeden Fall, wir hätten nie gedacht, dass wir es bis zu Folge 75 schaffen. Und ich glaube auch nicht, dass wir es bis zu 85 schaffen. Kurzen Disclaimer muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, ich habe gerade Nudeln gegessen. Ich habe zum Mittag ganz viel Nudeln gegessen und dann hat meine Kollegin nur die Hälfte ihrer Nudeln gegessen und dann habe ich deren Nudeln auch jetzt gerade noch gegessen. Das heißt, ich bin voller Nudeln und ich bin gerade in so einer Postmittag Depression. Postnudel Depression. Postnudel Depression und bin jetzt in einer, ich habe Penne gegessen. Bitte? Penne habe ich gegessen. Du bist zehn Zentimeter vor meinem Gesicht. Es gibt keine Möglichkeit, dass du mich nicht verstehst, Stefan. Tingel. Okay, was war das für Penne? Achso, das ist die Art der Nudeln, ne? Richtig, Pasta. Ich sage ja Pasta, aber gut. Du hast heute gekocht für das ganze Team, ich habe davon gegessen und muss sagen, es war okay. Ja, das freut mich doch, das war in Ordnung. Ja, wir hatten zu viele Nudeln für die Pfanne und dann haben wir zwei Pfannen benutzt und naja. Für mich genau durch den Prozess. Wie viele Pfannen waren zunächst da? Ich weiss, du bist gerade in einer Phase, in einer emotionalen Phase, weil vielleicht möchtest du ja nicht so gerne darüber reden, aber es ist tatsächlich etwas ges geschehen. Ich weiß nicht, ob du darüber sprechen möchtest, aber... Das ist für uns alle, glaube ich, kein einfacher Moment. Liebe Podcast-Ufo-Hörer, Jeff ist tot. Jeff hat es nicht überlebt, er hat die letzte Folge nicht überlebt. Ich bin nach Hause gekommen nach der letzten Folge und er war nicht mehr da. Und jetzt heisst es natürlich, es liegt an uns, wir werden damit umgehen. Ich würde sagen, wir bleiben alle aber kurz ein bisschen auf dem Boden einfach. Wir bleiben, wir wollen jetzt nicht durchdrehen, wir müssen... Einzige, was wir tun können, ist eine Schweigeminute. Ich möchte auch, dass alle Hörer, die Menschen um sich herum, dazu bitten, für einen Moment in sich zu gehen, alle Momente Revue passieren zu lassen, die wir mit Jeff erlebt haben.
Eine Schweigeminute.
Kurz eine Schweigeminute für Jeff.
Ab jetzt.
Einen guten Kampffisch. . . Jeff, wir vermissen dich. Ja, und ich finde, da ist auch mal Zeit, kurz die Comedy beiseite zu schieben, kurz meinsthaft zu sagen, weil das ist glaube ich der Moment, wo Comedy aufhört und wo das Leben anfängt. Das Leben. Wo das Leben auch aufhört. Ja, anfängt, aufhört. Ich hoffe, deine kleinen, starken Flossen tragen dich jetzt durch eine bessere Welt, Jeff, und du kannst. Sind die auch im Himmel? Weil der Himmel ist ja eigentlich nichts Gutes für Fische. Himmel ist das Gegenteil von dem, was Fische wollen, glaube ich. Ja, das stimmt schon. Aber freust du dich, ihn wiederzusehen irgendwann mal? Ich glaube nicht, dass ich ihn niemals wiedersehen werde. Das ist auch so ein Ding, dass man alle immer glauben, dass ihre Bekannten wieder sind im Himmel. Als ob da ... Die ganzen Leute, von denen man Gags gestohlen hat und so, trifft man alle wieder. Ist das wirklich ein Gag, den ich gerade in diesem Moment klaut habe? Bist du sicher? Okay, aber ja, anscheinend sind halt sehr viele Leute schon tot. Das stimmt, ja, es ist nicht leicht. Es wird auch immer schwerer mit der Zeit, haben wir auch schon mal gesagt. Dadurch, dass viele Sachen aufgenommen werden heutzutage, gibt es immer mehr Stuff und dadurch kann man immer weniger originelle Dinge machen. Weißt du, vor 10.000 Jahren hast du noch jemanden Gag gemacht und bist in den Nachbarsdorf gelaufen und hast denselben Gag gemacht. Niemand ist jemand drauf gekommen, dass das nicht dein Gag war, aber heute kam die Twitter-Polizei. Weil da war so ein Gefühl in der Luft. Ich glaube, da war auch so ein Gefühl, der ist nicht von dir, den hast du irgendwo gehört.
Ja, schade. Ich glaube, irgendwann ist dieses Projekt auch dann für den Arsch. Es wird nur noch eine Zusammenfassung der besten Gags. Aber hat der auch irgendwas. In welcher Folge hast du ihn gekauft? Du hattest ihn ja während der, da lief der Podcast schon, ne? Ja, auf jeden Fall. Gute Frage. Wie viele Podcast-Folgen hat er jetzt gelebt? Von einem Jahr ungefähr, ne? Ja, ungefähr von einem bisschen mehr als mehr. Die Fans können ja gerne mal in die Kommentare schreiben, bei welcher Folge, die, die sich noch erinnern, ich glaube, das dürfte höhere Generationen eins bis drei gewesen sein, auf jeden Fall die Elite, die höhere Elite, falls sich noch daran erinnert, bei welcher Folge Stefan seinen Fisch alleine im Treppenhaus hat zurückgelassen und in den schmierigen Fängen seiner gierigen Nachbarn verlassen hat. Ich nehm da fing an, dass sich das Leben von Jeff langsam auflöst. Ja. In Richtung, dass die Freude in seinen glasigen, eh schon glasigen Fischaugen.
In dem Fischglas, also in einer Menge Glas auf jeden Fall. Eine Menge Glas dazwischen, ja. Hat sich langsam aufgelöst. Aber wie würde es, hat er ein schönes Leben, wie würdest du eine Beziehung beschreiben? Also war es erzählt, oder? Gute Beziehung, sehr gute Beziehung, sehr enge Beziehung. Hat er sich immer gut verstanden? Immer gut verstanden, immer einen Gag auf den Lippen gehabt, immer einen Spruch auf den Lippen, Lippen, weiss ich nicht. Ja, weiss nicht genau. Dieser Fisch ist Anfang des Fisches. Immer gut. Ich habe Fotos gefunden mit uns zusammen im Heidepark, auf Mallorca, Malotze, wie wir immer gesagt haben, auf Sylt, wir haben alles mitgemacht. Ihr habt auch dieses doppelte Fahrrad gemietet und seid am Strand entlang gefahren. Richtig, aus der Achterbahn haben wir auch noch diese lustigen Fotos. Ja, ja. Mit den Augen zu, aber mit dem Mund war er auf. In die Wasserrutsche, er war völlig gelangweilt. Wasserrutsche ist so sein Thing einfach. Aber du warst total hibbelig. Ich war mega aufgefallen. Tolle Fotos, können wir vielleicht ein paar davon haben. Toll. Jeff, was hast du gemacht? Hast du ihn einen kleinen Grab bereit, eine kleine Prozession irgendwie? Ja, wenn du Müll einmal als Grab bezeichnen willst, dann ist er jetzt in einem Grab. Okay. War die Müllabfuhr schon da oder ist... Das weiß ich nicht. Da noch. Das weiß ich nicht, ne. Aber hast du den Müll schon rausgebracht jetzt? Auf jeden Fall, weil das roch auch schon zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo ich nach Hause gekommen bin, ein bisschen... Du meintest, da waren schon Schnecken auf seinem Leitnam drauf und haben ihn direkt... Ja, das will ich jetzt prozisieren. Das wäre eben nicht... Ja, das ist, du, Du baust dir da ein Biotop auf in deinem Zimmer, in deinem Wohnzimmer, du holst dir ein Stück Taiwan in deinem Wohnzimmer und natürlich sind das Schnecken, natürlich ist da die harte Natur am Start. Wenn da Garnelen reinkommen, dann beißt der die tot einfach, der beißt die durch in der Mitte. Und wenn die Oma vor dem Kampffischglas sitzt und sich freut, dass sie dem Enkel Garnelen geschenkt hat, dann beißt er die tot und ist Blut im Wasser. Aber das ist einem halt die wilde Natur. Das ist das Schauspiel, was du dir dann in deinem Wohnzimmer holst. Aber hast du das Tolle daran? Willst du jetzt die Schnecken weiterhin als Haustiere benutzen? Nein, ich habe sie instant einfach ausgekippt im Garten und das Aquarium ist jetzt aufgelöst. Der Tisch ist jetzt leer, wo vorher das Aquarium stand, der ist jetzt leer. Da ist nur noch ein Kre Kreuz. Dann bist du wieder alleine mit deinem AT-ST aus Lego. Ja, es ist wieder so, wie es begonnen hat. Mein Leben dreht sich im Kreis. Aber was kommt als nächstes? Vielleicht so ein Gecko oder sowas? Nee, gar nichts, glaube ich. Willst du jetzt die Nahrungskette langsam nicht so hocharbeiten oder so, jetzt mal einen Landtibesen oder so, einen Vogel vielleicht? Das finde ich schlecht. Ich habe überlegt, was wirklich ein cooles Haustier hat, was nicht jeder hat, was für ein cooles Haustier ist. Ein Wochen. Ja, sowas. Aber das ist ja wieder immer schnell aufwendig. Ich dachte auch, so einen Leguan finde ich ziemlich cool oder so halt diese Chamäleons, die einfach durch eine Wohnung mit so einer auf dieser Riesenzunge, weisst du, die mit der Riesenzunge. Hast du dich schon mal gesehen? Die haben eine wahnsinnig lange Zunge. Das stimmt, ja, und können ja auch Farbe wechseln, das ist auch nicht schlecht. Kannst du vor den Fernseher stellen und dann gucken, wie schnell sie sind. Ob die auch 3D zeigen können? Das ist ein guter, da kannst du ja Miami-Wise durch so eine Chameleon sehen. Du stellst es dann so vor dein Fernseher und dann kannst du ein bisschen... Aber nochmal die Frage, wenn Miami-Wise in 3D läuft, sieht man dann durch das Chameleon auch 3D oder ist es nicht 3D-ready? Wie viele Frames hat so ein Chameleon eigentlich die Frage?
Gute Frage, ist es HD-ready schon oder ist es noch Full-HD? Bläh, Bläh, Yesterday's Chameleon! Oh mein Gott, Stay Home! Oh mein Gott, Stay Home! Es tut mir leid, ich bin noch im Nudellirium, ich bin noch nicht ganz fit irgendwie.
Was ist denn Liebllich Nudel? Penne. Ich bin ein grosser Penne-Fan. Ich durfte heute auch die kulinarische Gewalt der Gruppe. Ich durfte Nudeln kaufen, habe Penne gekauft, das sind die besten Nudeln, einfach wegen der Röhrenform. Das ist einfach das Beste, weil man kann, wenn die Nudel zu heiß ist, ein Problem, das ich persönlich oft habe, kann man durch den Kanal durchpusten und erzeugt dadurch so einen negativen Kamineffekt, der der Nudel ganz schnell ganz viel Wärme entzieht und dann ist sie ganz schnell was dazu führt, dass er eine Nudel aus deinem Mund schießt, in das Gesicht deines Nachbarn. Und so sind schon gute Freundschaften entstanden. Ich finde, Penne ist schön, weil es noch massiv ist, also du spürst den Teig noch, wohingegen wenn du Spaghetti sind sehr dünn, halt einfach, das ist ein riesen Problem, das ist das grösste Problem und das grösste Vorteil. Der grösste Vorteil. Aber ich bin gerne jemand, der nur einen Nudel im Mund hat, zur gleichen Zeit. Ja, weiss ich nicht. Jo, also wie gesagt, das ist die Geschichte mit Jeff vorbei. Aber halt das auf dem Laufenden, wenn wieder ein neues Haustäter vorbeikommt und die neue überlegst. Du, ich bin Fehlkauf, Stefan. Ich spüre die Tiere durch meine Wohnung. Ich finde es ein hart, dass es Jeff als Fehlkauf mit seiner Hinesweiz ist. Nein, nein, nein, das wollte ich nicht, das wollte ich nicht so rüberkommen. Du tust ihm recht. Ich habe ihn auch mal kennengelernt, er ist ein netter Typ. Das war kein Fehler. Aber es war echt sehr klein. Bei Kampffisch habe ich mir immer so eine Kampfmaschine vorgestellt, mit so zwei Schwertköpfen und so einer Motorsäge an der Flosse, aber das war echt ein winzig kleines Ding. Ja, winzig klein, aber trotzdem eine Tötungsmaschine. Ist schon interessant. Ich war kein Fehlkauf, definitiv nicht. Freut mich. Du hast aber auch, du kommst jetzt jeden Tag nur mit so neuen Kratzern in deiner Hand in die Firma. Ja, ich war es verwochen, aber meine Eltern haben meine alte Katze, meine Kampfkatze besucht. Die ist ja, also das ist so ein bisschen, das ist wie in so einem Film, ich habe sie ausgebildet und habe sie dann ziehen lassen. Also der Schüler, sie wurde dann irgendwann sehr stark. Du hast sie an den Dolchen ausgebildet. Ich habe sie ausgebildet an der Kralle, an der Klaue und am Zahn. Und ich habe sie ausgebildet zu einer vollendeten Kampfmaschine und bin jetzt losgezogen und sie ist sich schon ihres alten Meisters bewusst. Also wenn ich im Raum bin, dann ist es für sie natürlich schon ein Erlebnis. Das heißt, wenn du nach Hause kommst, musst du das erstmal mit deinem Haus zurückerobern als Alphatier. Ne, ne, ne, das ist schon so, sie macht es einerseits, sie weiss ganz genau, wenn ich da bin, und dann plötzlich findet man vor seiner Tür so eine tote Maus. Aber sie ist nirgendwo, sie ist nirgendwo zu sehen. Sie an der Decke wahrscheinlich einfach. Ich weiss es nicht, sie ist nirgendwo, aber vor meiner Tür tote Maus. Okay, alles klar. Am nächsten Tag verstreicht, nirgendwo, sie ist nirgendwo zu sehen. Sie an der Decke wahrscheinlich einfach. Ich weiss nicht, sie ist nirgendwo, aber vor meiner Tür tote Maus. Okay, alles klar, am nächsten Tag verstreicht, nirgendwo gesehen, dann wieder toter Vogel. Und dann am letzten Tag, kurz bevor ich abreiss, eine tote Pizza, liege ich dann da irgendwo, lese ich da irgendwie ein Estet-Magazin oder sowas auf dem Sofa, ganz gut, dann kommt sie so ganz normal vorbeigeschlebt und so, hallo, hi, bist du auch da nett, dann wechselt man ein paar unangenehme Worte, so ah und wie geht's vor allem. Du meinst, sie will dir erstmal zeigen, dass sie noch töten kann? Weil der Chef ist einfach, sie weiss, du siehst mich nicht, aber ich kann töten. So und das ist die Kombination, die ich ihr beigebracht habe, das ist genau die richtige Kombination. Ist das ein Zeichen, ich kann auch dich töten, wenn ich wollte? Absolut, natürlich, könnte sie auch, könnte sie auch, wenn sie wollte. Sie hält im Gegensatz zu meiner WG-Katze, die ihre gesamte Kraft gegen mich wirft und deswegen auch wirklich Kratzer erzeugt, weiss meine Hauskatze bei mir zu Hause, weiss wann Schluss ist und die kann sich zurückhalten. Ja, aber es hat mich gefreut, es wiederzusehen, sie ist immer noch gut dabei. Katzen leben lange, also vielleicht zu Fischen leben die ultralange. Das stimmt, ja, die ist acht Jahre alt. Ich habe auch überlegt, wie alt mein Fisch wohl in Menschenjahren war, weil die werden halt nur ungefähr zwei Jahre alt. Das heißt, man kann das nicht so gut umrechnen wie bei Hunden, wo man das besser umrechnen kann, weil die halt wesentlich länger leben, die leben 14 Jahre, das kann man besser auf 80 zum Beispiel umrechnen. Wohingegen, wenn er einen Monat länger gelebt hätte, wäre er vielleicht 86 geworden, wo er jetzt nur 74 geworden ist. Das stimmt. Vielleicht war er 12 in Menschenjahren, vielleicht war er 133 in Menschenjahren. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Das ist schwer zu sagen. Und es ist auch interessant, dass sie dich überholen. Also du holst das Tier und du bist älter als das Tier, aber irgendwann überholen die dich in ihrer Lebenserwartung. Irgendwann sind die eigentlich älter als du, also von der Lebenserfahrung, die ihnen als Spezies offen liegt. Und dann ist es schon merkwürdig, weil das normalerweise nicht so ist. Wenn jemand jünger ist als du, ist er dein Leben lang jünger als du. Hast du da mal drauf geachtet? Ja, weil das Umrechnen ist. Wenn du dich in den Fischjahren umrechnest, bist du immer älter als er. Andere Geschichte. Tiere haben Leben auf der Erde, die weitaus älter sind als wir alle zusammen, als die meisten Organismen. Und das ist doch toll. Was haben die alle schon miterlebt? Was haben die? Die haben die Dinosaurier aufsteigen sehen, fallen sehen, viel fallen und dann nochmal aufsteigen sehen, dann kurz zwischenzeitlich die Orks aufsteigen sehen, fallen sehen, die Gnorme und jetzt wir und unter anderem du. Wie viel glaubst du, fühlen die sich, diese Tiere, sind die nicht ein bisschen verwirrt, weil es ist schon seltsam, was gerade passiert. Ich glaube, je länger du lebst, desto mehr scheissegal ist dir alles. Ja, oder? Das merkt man jetzt schon so an sich und du denkst, du siehst halt so alte Leute irgendwie im Zug, wo ein Hoden raushängt und die einfach durch die Gegend brüllen und stinken. Du denkst ja einfach, ja gut, eigentlich nervig, aber auf der einen Seite auch ein cooler Typ, weil dem ist halt einfach alles scheissegal, also für den ist das ja supergut. Und irgendwann hört man ja auch auf, wenn man rückwärts aus der Ausfahrt rausfährt, hört man auf, nochmal über die Schulter zu schauen. Man fährt einfach raus und wenn da jemand ist, oh mein Gott, dann ist da halt jemand. Irgendwann sagt man ja, scheiss egal, ich bin alt, die Biel, mir ist eh egal. Und du denkst ja, rückwärts gegangen und mal gucken, was passiert. Einfach mit mehr Risiko und Spaß. Das Kind mit der Fahne und dem Fahrrad hängt jetzt dazwischen, dann gibst du nochmal. Ja, und dann brettest du durch. Also ich kann das schon respektieren, ich glaube, bei Tieren ist es genauso. Wenn die einfach ein gewisses Alter erreicht haben, dann ist denen einfach alles scheißegal. Und dann haben die ihr Salatblatt vor Augen, so eine Schildkröte, und mehr auch nicht. Hm, Podcast-Tipp. Also Leute fragen mich oft nach Podcast-Tipps. Ne, Podcaster-Tipp. Für Leute, die Podcasts aufnehmen, fragen oft, wie machst du das, wie bist du seit Jahren so genial da drin, Podcasts aufzunehmen und dann habe ich jetzt zum ersten Mal eine Antwort gefunden.
Heute habe ich eine Antwort. Nein, das Mikrofon, was ihr benutzt, immer in einem Rucksack lagern, in dem Fisherman's Friends Cherry ausgelaufen sind, einfach die Packung leer ist, weil es riecht, dieser Schaumstoff-Knauf, der riecht gerade einfach nach, nicht mal da dran. Oh stimmt, das ist ein interessanter Geruch. Man will sich nicht mal so da reinschmusern. Und deswegen bist du immer ganz nah an deinem Mikrofon dran und deswegen klingst du auch immer so erotisch direkt. Diese ASMR-Videos, die jetzt gerade so ein bisschen viral gehen. Ja, die vor zehn Jahren viral gegangen sind. Ja, aber die jetzt krass werden. Ist das so? Nee, vor zehn Jahren schon? Ja, die gibt es schon eine Weile, ja. Aber ist okay. Ich suche mal kurz raus. Du bist Late Adopter, das ist in Ordnung. Ja, was ist mit denen? Also ASMR bedeutet Automatic System Meridian Response oder sowas. Das bezeichnet Gänsehaut. Und die klopfen dann immer so ans Mikrofon und da kratzen da rum und da gehen da ganz langsam dran.
Und das Krasseste, was ich jetzt nicht habe, ist, dass Leute so Boosterpacks von so Pokémonkarten und so auspacken.
Und das ist so ein ganz, glaube ich, so ein ganz spezifischer Fetisch von manchen Leuten, unter anderem von mir.
Ich finde das wahnsinnig beruhigend.
Ja.
Leute, ich kenne die Karten nicht, ich weiß nicht, sind die gut, sind die selten, aber sie packen halt diese knisternde Funde, die man sich als Kind gekauft hat, im Kiosk für zwei Euro oder so. Ich kann mich noch an das Gefühl erinnern, an diese Festigkeit der Karten in dem Papierding. Und vor allem, die machen es auch immer so, die sind ja immer gleich aufgebaut, die Booster Packs, und die seltenen Karten sind immer, glaube ich, an dritter, vierter Stelle halt. An dritter oder vierter Stelle, und die machen es immer so, dass sie den nach hinten mischen, dass sie, bevor bevor die angucken, mischen die die seltenen Karten nach hinten, damit sie dann irgendwie erst die unseltenen anschauen oder die häufigen anschauen und dann bis nach hinten zu den seltensten kommen. Und es so dramaturgisch aufbauen. Da dachte ich mir auch, wow, geil. Das ist ziemlich cool. Da weiß man genau noch, wie es angefühlt hat, wie es geknistert hat und so. Und ich glaube, man ist da auch dann sehr, sehr empfindlich, wenn man das hört nochmal. Das fand ich echt ziemlich cool. Ich dachte mir immer, die Karten sind nie wieder so perfekt wie jetzt. Ab jetzt sind die verfallen, die ab jetzt drücken die sich irgendwo ein und du hast sie für einen kurzen Moment in der Hand.
Ja, in einem perfekten Zustand.
Das ist wirklich, glaube ich, auch vielleicht ein ganzes Spektrum an Phänomenen und Gefühlen, die Kinder heutzutage vielleicht gar nicht mehr so haben.
So dieses Dinge fürs erste Mal in der Hand haben, so eine Actionfigur oder so ein Comic-Heft oder so Pokémon-Karten, weil heute ist ja alles digital und die laden sich ihren Spaß runter und dann essen die eine Tablette und haben irgendwie ein tolles Abenteuer Weltraumerlebnis und haben dann irgendwie ein tolles Abenteuer oder so, lame. Aber wir hatten ja damals noch Digimon und Beyblade und das ja das erste Mal aus der parken und sagen, das war ja schon, das war ja schon, das war ja schon, das war ja ruhig. Ich mag das ja nicht, diese Nostalgie-Scheisse, sind wir offen, das ist Luke Mockridge. Aber Beyblade, das ist schon, das war wirklich ein, wo man diese Arenen hatte, aus so dünnen Plastik. Bei uns hatten die die Trottel in der Klasse Beyblade und wir dachten uns scheisse drauf und wir haben uns die selber gebaut aus Lego einfach. Wir haben uns selber aus Lego Beyblades gebaut und haben die dann halt immer perfekt zu. Ja, deswegen gehen. Ja, aus Legotechnik, klar, kannst ja so einen Stiel in die Mitte und dann baust du da halt so Zahnräder rum und dann noch so Haken, wo dann der Gegner dranhängen bleibt. Ich glaube, das sind Leute aus der Informatik AG oder diese Informatik-Scheiss-Kerle, wo wir dachten, wir kaufen uns die einfach beim Kiosk, da sind die geil, da sind die geil aus, die Geschichten sind die aus dem Anime, fuck it, die bauen sich die selber. Wir haben die halt dann immer optimiert und so im Perfekt und halt wie bei diesem Robot-Fight dann immer so genau geschaut, wo sind die Schwächen des Gegners, muss man ihn eher oben treffen, muss man ihn eher unten treffen und wo ist die Verteidigung und haben das dann tatsächlich so durchgeballert. Das war eigentlich ganz geil so. Robot-Files sind ziemlich gut. Also unsere Dropbox muss man sich nicht vorstellen, ist so aufgebaut. Wir haben die Folgen unterteilt, dass man immer, einer schneidet die und veröffentlicht die dann. Und das ist eigentlich alles, was da drin ist.
glaube ich ein Dokument gibt es noch ein leeres, wo die Bestauffolge und dann ein Dokument Ideen, das komplett leer ist. T-Shirt-Ideen und dann gibt es einen Ordner, Roboter-Fails.
Ja, ein Ordner, ne?
Ein Ordner, wo ganz viele Gifs und so drin sind, die von Robotern handeln, die versagen. Weil das ist uns mal irgendwann aufgegangen, das Lustigste ist, was man im Internet findet. Ja, sind scheiternde Roboter, einfach so Roboter, die zu einem Zweck gebaut werden, aber denen verfehlen einfach. Aber sie sind extrem schlecht Fussball. Und man sich denkt, okay, heute haben wir Killer-Drohnen, wir haben den heißesten Scheiss, wir haben irgendwelche Nanobots, die in deinen Adern irgendwie Krebs töten oder sowas. Aber dann hast du so einen Fussballroboter, dann steht der Torwartroboter da und der Ball rollt dann ihm vorbei und vier Sekunden später lässt er sich in die falsche Richtung fallen. Und schmeißt auch die Arme dann im Liegen. Genau, hoch. Und dann einfach einfach unfassbar. Er ist ein Roboter, der halt schiessen will, aber dabei erst stolpert, dann aber den Ball stolpert, die sich hinfällt. Das ist schon ziemlich geil. Vor allem, das ist auch dieses, was wir immer angesprochen haben, dieses für allen Zweck geschaffen worden, den Sinn des Lebens Wissen, aber nicht erfüllen können. Ich glaube, das ist schlimm. Du bist bist ein Roboter, Fussballroboter, der schlecht Fussball spielen kann. Das ist dein Schicksal. Das ist eigentlich eine sehr, ich glaube, auch da Comedy kommt aus Tragödie und ich glaube, es ist ein sehr tragisches Schicksal, zu wissen, du bist halt ein Staubsaugeroboter, aber du bist halt auf dem Rücken und so, du kannst nicht staubsaugen. Die meisten Leute, habe ich gelesen, geben ihren Staubsaugerroboter Namen. Ja Leute versuchen immer, das ist aber diese Hör-Idee, wie gut können Artificial Intelligence-Sys sein, damit man sagt, okay, Leute nehmen die wahr als Objekt, die personifizieren das, die geben dem Namen vielleicht sogar. Aber dann ist irgendwann Wissenschaftler aufgefallen, wir müssen uns nicht so viel Mühe geben, Artificial Intelligence besonders menschlich erscheinen zu lassen, weil Menschen geben sogar schon Staubsaugerroboter Namen. Und so Rasenmäherroboter, die haben alle Namen, weil die, das ist schon, Menschen brauchen nicht viel. So es reicht, wenn jemand regelmäßig irgendwas macht, sondern er wird einfach so als Haushalt, dann kommt er auch in die Klingel, so diese Klingelstelle, wo dann steht Stefan, Marco. Oder irgendwann so eine Hochzeitseinladung, herzlichen Ladefeuerzeit mit Ben und dem kleinen Koko und dann so ein kleiner Radabdruck einfach, so wer so drüber gefahren ist. Und der ist Teil der Familie, der gehört zu uns. Ja, der ist Teil der Gruppe. Ja, klar, irgendwann kannst du da halt dann auch die Asche von der Oma draufstellen und dann fährt die durch die Gegend. Und mehr hat Oma dann auch nicht mehr gemacht, als sie 80 war. Ohne nicht und dann kannst du dann auch alle paar Stunden so ein so ein After-Aid ... Da musst du noch so ein Diktiergerät draufstellen, was die ganze Zeit abspült. Meckerscheiss, Hitler war alles besser, SS-Uniform raufziehen. Alle halbe Stunde so ein After-Aid rein und dann ist eigentlich auch Omi wieder am Leben. Also es ist ja dann nicht so schwer. Mehr war Omi dann auch nicht mehr, oder? Im Grunde nicht. Im Grunde echt nicht? Nee, wirklich nicht. Die Katze hat sie nicht mehr gefüttert. Nee, die Katze hat sie nicht mehr gefüttert, da ging gar nichts mehr zwischen den beiden. Ich glaube, ich wäre auch gerne, weil als Kind wollte ich immer entweder Roboter oder Eskimo werden. Das war einfach meine Traumvorstellung. Du hast als Kind schon sehr unrealistische Berufsvorstellungen gehabt. Das stimmt, ja. Wir hatten diese Shirts, die man sich anziehen konnte, man sah aus, das ist instant wie ein Polizeimann. Ja, das nicht. Da hatte ich immer Angst, erschossen zu werden. Dann dachte ich mir, die Leute denken, ich bin echter Polizist und ich werde erschossen. Dann berate ich in so einen Mafiakrieg und du hast ein sehr artikuliertes Kind. Ich hatte als Kind immer so die Vorstellung, dass Polizisten am laufenden Band erschossen werden. Ich dachte mir, er ist polizistisch schon cool, aber da lebt man halt nicht lange. Bis seit Ausbildung trittst du aus der Reviertür, okay, Gerechtigkeit, hier kommt ein neuer Verfechter und zack, du bist sofort tot. Aber nach der Logik würden, glaube ich, Polizisten am längsten leben, weil in einer Welt, wo man andauernd erschossen wird, haben Polizisten, glaube ich, doch die beste Chance, sich zu wehren. Ja gut, nee, ich dachte, dass die halt so gefährlich leben und so, deswegen, dass die halt ständig, weil die Brauchern scheiden, Waffen um sich zu verteidigen, weil den ganzen Tag irgendwie Dinge, Beeren und Hirsche greifen die an und die müssen sich immer verteidigen gegen alles.
Was war denn ein Vorstellungs von einem Feuerwehrmann? Alles die haben so ein bisschen Lava, Feuer. Ja, ich dachte immer, dass Feuerwehrmänner immer so in das Feuer reingeworfen werden. Weil ich hatte so ein Computerspiel und da musste man so Feuerwehrleute so ins Feuer werfen, damit die die löschen. Und die hat man immer so direkt in die Flamme reingeworfen. Was war das für ein Spiel? Ich weiß es nicht mehr genau, aber da hatte man so, man hatte so eine Stadt, ich weiss nicht, vielleicht kenne ich das Spiel, man hatte so eine Stadt und unten hatte man so eine Reihe von Leuten, so einen Arzt und so einen Polizisten und Feuerwehrmann und irgendwie Leute und dann sind immer Dinge passiert und dann musste man die richtigen... Du hast die große Hand gehabt, ne? Genau, dann musste man die richtigen Leute an die richtigen Orte so droppen und wenn das gebrannt hat, musste es wieder so fünf Feuerwehrleute draufwerfen, auch ohne Equipment oder so, Aber wurden, einfach die Leute halt selbst und die haben dann mit ihren blossen Händen, haben die dann so die Flammen kaputt gedrückt und dann werden dann halt irgendwo... Und die Vorbeamänner haben noch gerufen, okay, dafür wurde ich gemacht, das ist mein Leben. Jetzt kann ich verbrennen und da ist halt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, ist ein Typ halt gegen den Baum gefahren und da hast du da halt lauter Ärzte drauf geworfen, damit er den wieder repariert und so, also ganz merkwürdig, keine Ahnung wie dieses Spiel heißt. Ich finde auch diese alten Spiele, die waren so geil, weil die halt so realistisch waren in manchen Punkten und dann wieder halt irgendwie das nicht durchgezogen haben in dem Spiel. Weil dann gab es bei Rollercoaster Tycoon war unfassbar geiles Spiel, ohne Frage. Und dann hast du ja auch, wenn eine Achterbahn einen Unfall gebaut hat und dann kamen auch wieder so Flammen und dann ist es runter auf die Erde gestossen und dann ist es explodiert und so und Menschen gestorben. Und dann hast du auch Strafe bezahlen müssen, weil du halt nicht den TÜV hast abnehmen lassen und so. Aber gleichzeitig, obwohl halt die Konsequenzen so die echten waren, wurde der Park nicht geschlossen. Das heißt, daneben sind Leute jubelnd noch in ihre Achterbahn gefahren. Mit ihrer Zuckerwahl in der Hand. Und genau vor der Explosion haben sich noch Leute irgendwie einen Burger geholt oder so einen Flutschfinger, wo man sich denkt, warum schliessen die den Park dann nicht? Also die haben das dann durchgezogen, aber halt die wollten die User Experience halt dann auch nicht komplett kaputt machen, haben dann gesagt, okay, das Spiel geht weiter, der Park wird nicht geschlossen oder sowas. Was natürlich so voll die Konsequenz wäre. Das ist schon lustig. Aber das habe ich gar nicht viel gespielt, tatsächlich. Erst später vielleicht. Ich habe immer Frippel verkaufen, hatten wir ganz früher. Ich hatte ja schon ganz früher einen Computer. Mein Vater ist ein großer Computerfreund, das auch von Apple und die ganz alten hatte. Deswegen hatte ich schon als ganz kleines Kind ab und zu Computer gespielt. Und da gab es einen Frippel verkaufen. Und dann hattest du so ein ganzes Regal voller Frippel. Das waren so kleine Wesen. Was sind Frippel? So mit Punkten und Streifen und grossen Augen und kleinen Augen. Und dann kam der Kunde und hat gesagt, ich hätte gerne einen Frippel mit Pink und Punkten und kleinen Augen. Und dann musstest du aus den ganzen Frippel musst du dann das richtige Frippel aussuchen und der Kundin geben und dann, okay, danke. Und wenn die Kunden angefangen haben zu brennen, musst du einfach ganz viel Luft, vorher wenn man auf Frippel reingeht. Drauf wäre bei mir die ganze Zeit, das hat sich durch das Ganze gezogen. Ne, das war abgefahren, ja. Ja. Naja. Ich glaube, ich wollte mal, also, aber das ist interessant, dass du Eskimo werden wolltest. Ja, ich glaube, ich habe echt eine Affinität für Kälte. Ich mag Kälte wirklich total gern. Also ich habe auch nichts gegen Kälte und wenn es mal kalt und nass ist, so habe ich echt nichts dagegen. Wird wieder kälter jetzt. Wohingegen, wenn es warm ist, dann bin ich sofort irgendwie schon am Kollabieren. Deswegen ist es eigentlich, dachte ich mir immer so, Eskimo eigentlich genau das Richtige. Und ich fand Iglus einfach so geil, einfach die Vorstellung davon, in dem Iglu zu wohnen, weil diese Rundform hat mich einfach fasziniert, irgendwie dieses pralle, runde. Diese runde, schön greifbar. Genau, das hat mich immer fasziniert, da fand ich immer. Obwohl ich bis heute nicht verstehe, wie genau Iglus funktionieren, irgendwie, weil das ist ja … Es ist so spannend, dass man mit den Mitteln der Kälte etwas baut, was dich warm hält. Das stimmt schon, das ist schon echt abgefahren. Das ist das Abgefahren daran. Vor allem der Eingang muss ja auch unterhalb deiner Schlafposition sein, ne, irgendwie sowas, habe ich mal so eine Grafik gesehen. Ja, das kommt ja auch Schwachsinn. Ja, das kommt ja auch schon. Ich habe neulich eine Doku gesehen und konnte danach nicht schlafen.
Und das passiert relativ häufig.
Und das war, habe ich davon erzählt,
aber für unsere Hörer, ich wollte da mit dir nochmal drüber sprechen,
weil ich es echt spannend finde. Es ist kompletter
Schwachsinn, aber es ist auch sehr interessant.
Der Mandela-Effekt.
Ja, da...
So, der Mandela-Effekt. Ist der Effekt, dass ein Grossteil der Menschen glauben, dass Nelson Mandela in den 80er Jahren in einem Gefängnis gestorben ist. Schwachsinn, er ist 2013 oder 11 oder 13 gestorben, halt irgendwann in den 2000er Jahren. Und viele Menschen dachten aber an seinem Tod, als er gestorben ist und die Nachricht gehört haben, haben viele gesagt, der ist doch in den 80er Jahren im Gefängnis gestorben.
Und das haben sehr viele gedacht. Und die haben nicht nur gedacht, der ist doch irgendwann schon mal gestorben, der ist doch schon tot. Nein, die waren sich sicher, dass er in den 80er Jahren in einem Gefängnis gestorben ist. Die hatten eine sehr konkrete Vorstellung von seinem Tod. Aber das ist jetzt keine Verschwörungstheorie. Nein, das ist Fakt. Sondern, nee, das ist jetzt keine Verschwörungstheorie, von wegen so ganz viele Leute denken, der wäre schon tot und bla, sondern der Effekt ist im Gegenteil so ein kollektives Falscherinnern. Genau, der Effekt ist ein kollektives, ich würde nicht sagen Falscherinnern, ich würde sagen Anderserinnern, als man es kennt. Auch der Effekt kommt auch zu tragen bei Star Wars. Viele sind der Meinung, dass C3PO komplett Gold ist. Stimmt nicht. Sein rechtes Bein, Unterschenkel ist silber. Haben viele gedacht, es stimmt nicht. Oder auch, dass Darth Vader sagt, Luke, du bist mein Vater. Äh, Luke... Das dachte ich eigentlich schon. Luke, ich bin dein Vater. Er sagt aber nur nein, ich bin dein Vater. Aber alle denken das. Das sind diese Dinge von kollektiven Fehlinterpretationen der ganzen Lage. Und das ist schon interessant, weil es ist wirklich, diese Doku war sehr gruselig aufgemacht und ich dachte mir die ganze Zeit, was, wenn sich andauernd die Realität ändert. Und manchmal hat man das Gefühl, man ist sich sehr sicher, dass man was im Kopf hatte und wie es gelaufen ist. Man hat eine sehr konkrete Vorstellung davon und dann war es halt ganz anders. Keiner hat passieren, aber das ist sehr viele Menschen das gleiche denken. Und die Theorie ist, dass irgendwie verschiedene Dimensionen für einen kurzen Moment überlappen und das einzige, was sie ändern, sind nicht die physikalischen Gesetze, sondern irgendwie, dass Nelson Mandela, dass viele Leute denken, dass Nelson Mandela in den 80er Jahren im Gefängnis gestorben ist. Es gibt Theorie eins, alle Menschen vertun sich, weil die irgendwie gleichzeitig eine Nachricht gehört haben, die sich erinnern oder so und die anders war. Oder weil Nelson Mandela irgendwie im 80er-Jahr gestorben ist und alle dachten so, ach so, ach nee, Nelson Mandela, ist mir eigentlich auch scheißegal. Da müsst ihr jetzt keine Doku drüber machen, ehrlich gesagt, das passt schon. Nee, nee, nee, nee, wir machen das schon. Der zweite Erklärungsansatz ist Glitch in der Matrix. Ja. Die Realitäten laufen zusammen und das einzige, was sich verändert, ist Nelson Mandela's Tod, weil die andere Dimension hat ihn gehasst. Ja, ich weiß nicht, also was soll man damit anfangen? Ich fand das sehr spannend, weil stell dir mal vor, von heute auf morgen gibt es uns nicht mehr und Leute sagen, ich habe doch das Gefühl, ich habe einen Podcast gehört und dann habe ich das Gefühl, dass Flotin Will war doch der, der in den 80er Jahren im Gefängnis gestorben ist oder sowas und dann sind wir einfach nicht mehr da.
Ich habe mal irgendein Argument gehört, warum wir nicht in einer Computersimulation sind, weil egal wie komplex diese Computersimulation sei, sie muss ja endlich sein, sie muss ja von irgendeinem Wesen erschaffen worden sein und sie muss einen Anfang haben und ein Ende haben. Und allein, dass es so Zahlen gibt wie Pi, die kein Ende haben und einfach unendliches Datenvolumen verbrauchen würden, weil sie schlicht kein Ende haben, allein das würde schon beweisen, dass wir nicht in der Computerdesimulation sind. Ist wahrscheinlich Schwachsinn, aber ich habe es einfach mal ausgeauert. Einfach mal schreibt man was dazu. Das leicht verdauliche Podcastsuche, da wir zum Einschlafen. Ja, ich muss tatsächlich zum Thema leicht verdaulich, ich tue mir schwer mit der Verdauung irgendwie. Du hast gerade ein Nudelproblem. Ich habe echt ein richtiges Nudelproblem momentan. Also diese Folge wird in die Geschichte eingehen als die Nudelfolge, weil... Würde sie, wenn das Puffpuffopedia noch existieren würde, was nicht der Fall ist. Doch, es existiert noch. Man muss nur, also jedes hundertste Mal, dass man sie aufruft, funktioniert sie. Aber man findet auch keine Seiten mehr, weil es ist mittlerweile so ein russischer Geheimdienst. Die russische Mafia hat da leider irgendwie seine Finger mit drin und hat das, kommt das übernommen eigentlich. Die meisten Bots im Internet verstehe ich einfach nicht, weil die keinen Sinn verfolgen. Und das macht doch keinen Sinn. Also die werden ja programmiert von Leuten, die irgendwas erreichen wollen. Die wollen entweder an ein Passwörter kommen, die wollen Malware aktivieren, die wollen halt irgendwas wollen die machen, die haben einen Zweck.
Aber ganz kurz, falls da jemand, sorry, falls da draussen jemand ist, der sich für diese Open-Source-Wikipedia-Seiten interessiert und da Bock hat, da sich reinzuarbeiten oder da schon Erfahrung gemacht hat oder irgendwie Informatik studiert oder irgendwie cool ist und Bock hat, uns zu helfen, weil an sich würde ich die Pubepedia schon gerne wieder starten.
Das Problem ist, ich weiss einfach nicht wie und ich weiss nicht wie man den fehler den wir hatten verhindern könnte weil ich krieg weiß einfach nicht wie es geht so und wenn er jemand bock hätte da irgendwie den der neue admin zu werden und so ist ja open source wir haben da eh keine übermacht jetzt über anderen außer dass wir vielleicht ein paar ideen einbauen wie das ganze aussehen hat aber wer da bock hat sich da irgendwie mal dran zu setzen, fände ich eigentlich ganz cool. Ja, finde ich auch cool. Damit wir auch einfach in der Vorbereitung der einzelnen Folgen wissen, welche Geschichten wir schon erzählt haben und wissen, okay, jetzt müssen wir nicht nochmal die Stefan Titzes Maus ist gestorben Geschichte erzählen. Fisch. Da ist immer eine Maus. Fredo, die kleine Maus. Wo glaubst du, ist diese Maus gestorben? Ähm, die ist doch schon vorher für locker 30 Jahre gestorben, oder? In Budapest?
Das hat meine Mutter gestern auch gesagt. Meine Mutter gestern auch beglebt ja nie eine Maus.
Klar, dass sie nicht... Ich war doch bei dir und hab die Maus gesehen.
Das ist das Phänomen des Mandela-Effekts. Als wir den Stand-Up vorbereitet haben, war ich bei dir, kurz bevor wir ins Boing-Oi-Oi-Oi-Oi-Oi-Oi-Oi-Oi-Oi-Oi-Oi-O mit dieser kleinen Treppe, wo die auf diesem Haus war. Ich hatte nie eine Maus. Fredo die Maus. Ich würde meine Maus nicht mal Fredo nennen. Wie sah die Maus aus? Maus Fredo? Ja. Ich hätte nie eine Mausflur entrieben. Ich hätte so einen Fleck um den linken, sah so aus, hätte sie ein blaues Auge, so ein schwarzer Fleck um das linke Auge. Haben Freunde von Bergstein auch gesagt. Ich hatte nie eine Maus. Ich hatte einen Fisch, come fish Jeff. Nee, meine Maus. Verarschen mich gerade, oder was soll das jetzt? Lebt Nelson Mandela noch? Ja, aber der ist halt gerade im Gefängnis. Ich habe gestern noch ein Interview mit ihm gesehen. Ich hätte Nelson Mandela bei mir zu Hause. Welche Nudeln habe ich... Maus Jeff ist in den 80er Jahren im Gefängnis gestorben. Welche Nudeln habe ich heute gegessen? Spaghetti. Okay, das stimmt. Hamzy. Hamzy. Wuhu! iOS 10 ist raus. Wie gefällt's dir? Die Apple Geeks. Topical Island. Topical Island, ich schneide das nicht. Topical Island, da musst du die Musik einschneiden. Ich habe da keinen Bock drauf, die mal reinzuschneiden. Du hast keine Aufgabe. Ich schneide den Podcast, ich veröffentne den Podcast. Ich schneide auch den, ich muss den Scheisschen, du drin, lässt nochmal schreiben. Ich schreibe den Titel. Nein, das stimmt nicht. Ich denke mir die Geschichten aus. Ich schreibe den Sendepart. Nein, da schneide ich alles raus. Ich schreibe den Skript für jede Folge. Ja klar, na gut. Was für ein Autor macht dich das, wenn du den Scheisschen auch noch schreibst? Lame, lame, lame, lame, lame, lame, lame, du kannst dich so oft hintern, das ist was lame. Authentizität. Das hast du falsch geschrieben, das steht da falsch drin. Naja, Topik der einen, iOS 10 ist raus, Stefan Titzer hat seine Finger an ein neues Gerät bekommen und will uns heute mal zeigen, wie das neue Feature aussieht.
Die Aktien-App wurde geupdatet und der Taschenrechner hat eine neue Neukurierung.
Kurz meine kleine Review zu iOS 10.
Mir gefällt es überhaupt nicht, ich finde es katastrophal, Apple hat sich seit Jahren zurückentwickelt, das ist ein krönigender Abschluss in iOS 10.
Ich finde es furchtbar, ich bin ein großer Apple-Fan, ich liebe die Produkte, ich finde die designmäßig schön, ich finde sie toll, wie sie miteinander fungieren. Ich finde es nur furchtbar, was iOS 10 da macht. Es ist unhandlich, man kann es nicht so gut entsperren, es ist gross, klobig und hässlich. Ein User hat mir geschrieben, dass er die Geschichte meiner Chemielehrerin letzte Woche interessant fand und sie genauso in Erinnerung hat, die Chemielehrerin.
Und dann habe ich gefragt, woher kennst du bitte die Frau, habe ich mir geschrieben. Er hat jetzt geschrieben, gerade geantwortet, erlischt sein Tüch.
Stefan, deine Mutter weint seit Tagen. Meine Mutter weint seit Tagen, ich werde deine ganze Familie verbrennen, hat sie gesagt.
Kommt bitte nach Hause.
Er hat geschrieben, dass er tatsächlich da auf dem Gymnasium war.
Krass, wow, Hörer von meinem Gymnasium. Jetzt muss ich ganz vorsichtig sein.
Wir haben heute auch das erste Mal von unserem Auftraggeber Spotify,
haben wir heute das erste Mal unsere Statistik bekommen und wissen jetzt, wer uns hört und
wir haben dich gefunden, wir haben einen Hörer aus Belgien.
Wer ist es, wer ist es, wer ist es, wer ist es, wer kann kurz mal aufstehen und schmeisst die Pölzer in die Hand, da hinten, achtzehnte Reihe, steht in seinen Holzschuhen da mit nem Käse unterm Arm, steht da rum, und schmeisst Pralinen auf die Bühne, wie geht's dir? Und drei aus Italien, ein Wachstum von 200%. Den höchsten Wachstum der ganzen Welt haben wir in Italien ein höheres Wachstum von 200%.
Das ist schon unfassbar.
Das heißt, wenn das so weitergeht, verdoppeln wir uns jede Woche in Italien. Das heißt, in spätestens zehn Jahren haben wir zwei Milliarden Hörer in Italien. Das sind wir viel grösser als alles andere, was jemals in Italien gross war. Ja, das stimmt. Das ist echt krass. Also die Statistik hat mich von den Socken gehauen. Auf jeden Fall, wir haben auf jeden Fall eine ganze Menge ausländische Hörer. Wäre natürlich schön, wenn ihr uns mal schreiben würde, vielleicht mit so einem Foto von euch am belgischen Strand oder sowas in der Richtung, dann können wir mal ein bisschen sehen, wie das Podcast übrigens auch in anderen Ländern landet.
Wir haben 74 Prozent Männer als Zuhörer. Ja, das ist ein bisschen peinlich. Weiß ich nicht. Das ist immer so ein Ding, wenn man sich sagt, naja, das ist wahrscheinlich ein Scheiß-Podcast.
Aber wie können wir die Frauen holen? Wie können wir die Frauen holen? Was können die T-Shirt sein? Wahrscheinlich ein bisschen weniger über Star-Wars-Verschwörungen reden, ist vielleicht schon mal der erste Schritt. Und ein bisschen weniger über Beyblade. Du hast neulich zehn Folgen lang kontinuierlich uns Bericht über deinen Penis, hier in diesem Podcast genannt. Ich weiß nicht, ob das vielleicht die Hörerin verschreckt hat. Wir können ja Hörerin bevorzugen. Wir lesen ab jetzt jede Nachricht, die wir von Hörerinnen bekommen, lesen wir im Podcast vor. Ab jetzt lesen wir jede Nachricht, egal welcher Inhalt, lesen wir vor. Ich möchte dich mal kurz unsern sympathisch dastehen lassen und dich mal kurz was fragen. Findest du es richtig, dass man immer Hörerinnen und Hörer schreibt, Schülerinnen und Schüler? Findest du es richtig, dass man das immer trennt? Fussgängerinnen und Fussgänger. Also ich habe da nichts dagegen. Mikrofoninnen. Ich bin jetzt, ja, das ist natürlich der gute Gag. Ich bin jetzt nicht so militant und sage, das ist irgendwie total scheiße und sperrig, das kann man schon machen. Aber ich persönlich mache das nicht immer, ausser wenn man jetzt konkret, wenn man sagt liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, wenn man sagt Hörer, ja, ich weiß nicht, ich habe mich da nicht mit Gender Studies nicht allzu intensiv beschäftigt, aber ich finde es sowohl nicht schlecht, wenn man es macht, mache es aber selber jetzt eigentlich ab und zu, aber sonst nicht oft. Okay. Aber ist okay, habe ich jetzt echt kein Problem damit. Das ist eine diplomatische Antwort. Da wollte dich einer aber nicht auf das Fenster lehnen, ne? Nee, nee, überhaupt kein, nee, meine ich. Ich finde es speichrig, wenn es so ist. Also ich finde es auch unnötig, weil
ich verbinde da nicht automatisch männliche Hörer
mit dem Wort Hörer. Ja, aber vielleicht andere Leute,
vielleicht, ne, ist ja, das ist ja immer
so das Ding, da kannst du ja sagen, ja, ich finde
es scheiße, aber du bist halt auch einfach die Herrenrasse.
Aber dann darfst du auch keine, genau, dann darfst du auch einfach
keine Gagse bei dem Holocaust machen.
Ja, das ist halt die Frage, wie man das argumentiert, ne,
ob man jetzt da selber, wer das entscheidet letztendlich.
Das ist immer die, das finde ich ein gutes Podcast-Ufascheid, es ist immer eine Frage, wie man das argumentiert, ob man jetzt da selber, wer das entscheidet letztendlich. Das ist nicht ein gutes Podcast-Ufascheid. Es ist immer eine Frage, wie man das argumentiert. Eine Aussage, die nichts aussagt. Komplett gar nichts. Ja, aber das sind halt so offene, manche müssen Fragen auch einfach offen bleiben. Manche muss man einfach die Spannung aushalten, die so eine Frage erzeugt. Man muss einfach auch Spannungen in sich, ich glaube viel Leid entsteht in der Welt dadurch, dass man zu schnell Spannungen auflöst und man sagt Ausländer ja oder nein und man sagt nein und dann ist Krieg oder sagst aber du sagst so ach ich habe keine Ahnung, jetzt lass mich in Ruhe. Ich glaube da entsteht relativ wenig Gewalt in dem man sagt ach ich bin da einfach offen für Ideen und ich glaube auch so ein Nazi könnte mich innerhalb von vier Minuten komplet komplett überzeugen und ich wäre morgen Neonazi. Nein, das glaube ich nicht. Ich glaube, wenn er ein paar gute Argumente hat. Stimmt, ich bin auch sehr begeisterungsfähig. Ich habe noch zu Recht wenig irgendwie starke Meinung, in der er sagt, ja, aber das ist ja, ja, nee, nee und so und dann wie die halt immer Sachen machen und dann so und dann, ja, komm, dann machen wir es halt so. Auch mal so Leute, die sagen, wenn ich damals geboren wäre, ich wäre kein Nazi gewesen. Ja klar bin ich Nazi gewesen. Ich bin ja erst leihärig gestanden. Hast du mal die Uniform gesehen, wie geil die aussah? Mega schick einfach. Hallo, mega gut. Nee, ich weiß nicht, damals wie so die Geschmacksvorstellungen waren, was die Leute cool fanden, aber wenn ich das Hakenkreuz als ein schönes Symbol empfunden hätte, was ich so ganz sexy finde, einfach schick, ich würde es gerne tragen. Du, ich habe auch schon mal eine Oper von Richard Wagner gehört und mir dachte, mein Gott, die Polen, die können auch mal weg jetzt, das braucht da jetzt kein Mensch. Und dann bist du mit deinem kleinen Twingo, bist du rübergefahren, kurz mal. Ich habe gesagt, ja, aber auch, um uns zu schiessen, ihr Spacken da, jetzt kommen wir mal rüber. Das habe ich auch schon gemacht und irgendwann erwischt man sich dann so, oh scheiße, was habe ich da eigentlich gerade gedacht. Und dann kann man sich schon verstellen, wenn solche... Und die Scheiben des Zwingos am Wackeln, weil die Musik so laut war und er wird an der Grenze hängen, weil er mit Alkohol um die Hand ist. Ich glaube, ab einem gewissen Zivilisationsstand war der Mensch einfach verloren.
Ich glaube, der Mensch ist rein körperlich nicht dazu gemacht, zu viel Freizeit zu haben. Und dann kommt er auf dumme Ideen. Der Mensch hat dazu gedacht, weißt du, so ein Esel, der rennt den ganzen Tag durch die Wüste oder Dschungel oder was auch immer und isst dann irgendwie seine Blüten und saugt dann den Nektar aus dem Pachter. Und. Der macht den ganzen Tag nichts anderes. Der Mensch, der lässt sich halt irgendwie sein Mac-Menü Deluxe kommen. Und er hat einfach zu viel Zeit. Und dann kommt das Gehirn. Reproduktion und Selbsterhaltung. Und das Gehirn kommt plötzlich ins Schwimmen, so, oh scheiße, das, was ich am besten kann, überleben und Sex haben, muss ich gar nicht mehr machen den ganzen Tag. Und das ist 99,9 meiner Kapazität und die letzten 0,1, die werfen wir jetzt mal an und heizen da mal richtig Energie rein. Und da kommt nur Scheiße bei raus, na klar. Aber das Interessante ist, wenn Tiere sterben wollen, nichts leichter ist das. Sie können, also das ist, sie müssen dagegen ankämpfen, nicht zu sterben, wohingegen wir Menschen, wir müssen uns anstrengen zu sterben. Es ist wirklich, also ich habe oft darüber nachgedacht, wenn ich mich jetzt umbringen wollen würde, wie würde ich das tun? Und mir fallen nur Wege ein, selbst wenn ich es wollen würde, wäre ich zu faul dazu, weil es ist viel Aufwand. Du musst dir eine Waffe besorgen, ich muss zu Rheinbrücke gehen, mich da runterschmeissen, nee, komm ey. Du musst dich anstre der... Du musst dich anstrengen zu sterben, also du bist vom Leben so mitgetrieben.
Ja, und deswegen ist der Mensch, glaube ich, per se leer.
Einfach, ich glaube, so ab nach Rom oder so, als es nach dem Mittelalter wieder aufwärts geht,
ab einem gewissen Punkt ist der Mensch einfach leer.
Er hat einfach, Religion ist weg und alles andere ist weg und dann ist man einfach leer.
Und wenn jemand sagt und kommt, hey Leute, ich habe hier diese schöne Karaffe, Antisemitismus, der ist richtig geil, dann sagt die, ja komm hier rein damit zu, nehmen die alle, weil die einfach leer sind und eh nichts zu tun haben und sagen, ach ja, dann machen wir halt das, bevor wir es gar nicht machen. Ja, aber es geht nur um Ideen.
Machen wir das halt so.
Leute kommen auf Ideen und Leute unterstützen Ideen.
Leute mögen Projekte einfach so, so einen Garten zum Beispiel, meine Eltern haben einen Garten und ich denke mir, will ich auch mal einen Garten haben?
Nee, aber auf der anderen Seite, auch wenn ich ihn gar nicht mag, denke ich mir, okay, dann irgendwie am Wochenende zum Baumarkt zu fahren und sich so eine Kralle zu kaufen und dann so durch die Gegend zu krallen irgendwie dann so, da hast du was zu tun. So und ich glaube, genau so haben die den Holocaust auch gesehen, so jetzt bauen wir halt mal ein KZ und dann gucken wir einfach mal was da geht. Und dann lief es ein, da waren sie im Fall. Und dann läuft es und dann so, ja das passt eigentlich so und nee, wir können die eigentlich noch ein bisschen besser bauen und Und hast du morgen Zeit, klar, treffen wir uns morgen um vier irgendwie.
Und dann bauen die das nächste und dann läuft es halt so langsam voran. Aber jetzt ist es ja so, dass sie im KZ nun mal Menschen umgebracht haben und im Garten deine Eltern nur einen Menschen jemals umgebracht haben. Ja, das stimmt. Und das ist natürlich so ein Ding, ja, Olli, und das ist auch so eine Frage, also ich meine, wo haben sie sich da dann verrannt? Also wo fängt man dann an, aus einem guten Projekt, aus einer guten Idee, ein Schwachsinn zu werden, eine Schwachsinnsidee. Man ist ja auch die Frage, kann man was für seine Überzeugungen und seine Meinungen? Ich meine, keine Ahnung, du denkst jetzt zum Beispiel, irgendwie Kapitalismus ist scheiße. Ich liebe dieses zwölfjährige Mädchen. Ja genau, du denkst ja, keine Ahnung, du machst irgendwie Kapitalismus dafür verantwortlich, dass es dir nicht gut geht oder dass es den Menschen zu schlecht geht. Aber jemand anders macht halt Juden dafür verantwortlich. Du denkst ja, ja gut, okay, kann man den, ich habe keine Ahnung, ist mir auch scheissegal, keine Ahnung, so kann man wirklich jetzt Hitler dafür verantwortlich machen oder mein Gott, lass den Jungen doch mal in Ruhe, immer dieses, dann gehen sie auf die Straße und sagen, die Nazis waren scheiße, die sagen mir, ach Leute, lass dir das doch mal in Ruhe. Ich finde aber, dass die Nazis erstaunlich viele Argumente gegen Juden erfunden haben. Also da ist schon viel Gedankengut reingeflossen. Mal überleg mal, also du kannst, dass du eine Gruppe, eine Glaubensgruppe für so viele Sachen verantwortlich machen kannst, da ist schon viel Marketing dahinter. Aber auf der anderen Seite eben so, das ist eigentlich schon, also ich kenne mich damit nicht gut genug aus, aber gab es da wirklich mal so Sachen? Keine Ahnung, jetzt könnte man zum Beispiel sagen, wenn man jetzt zurückblickt, Geschichte der Flüchtlinge, dann kann man sagen, ja okay, da gab es Köln, Silvester, das war der erste historische Moment, da war es scheisse, danach wurde die Stimmung schlechter, Rechtspopulisten ergreifen immer mehr Macht, irgendwie immer mehr Präzedenzfälle, Flüchtlinge brennen, dann gibt es Eskalation und irgendwann haben die gesagt, komm wir schmeissen die jetzt alle ins Meer und dann sind die alle ins Meer geflogen und dann waren die alle tot. Und zehn Jahre später arbeitet man das im, wie viele Leute, wann muss der, wann, wann stoppt der Wahnsinn endlich, ist meine Frage. Wann hört endlich dieser scheiss Wahnsinn mal auf und wir können endlich wieder zurück zu, was war dein letztes Jahr Thema? Was war dein letztes Projekt? Ja, da war Thema Griechenland. So, die scheiss Drecksgriechen trinken unseren Uso und fahren in ihren scheiss kleinen Motorbooten rum und fahren den ganzen Flüchtlingskindern hier die Schuhe kaputt, werden sie hier rum und gewinnen die WM. So, das war letztes Jahr, Jahr davor. Irakkrieg, ach Gottchen, mein Gott, dann fliegen die mit ihren scheiß Flugzeugen in irgendwelche Sandhügel rein und machen da Leute kaputt und wir schauen uns das an von der Ferne und sagen, ach Gott, was läuft denn auf RTL 2 King of Queens.
So, das ist nämlich mal meine Meinung, dass es so nicht weitergehen kann.
Das waren noch Zeiten, wo man sich denkt, mein Gott, da war die Welt noch einfacher. Mittlerweile, oh die Clinton, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, Mittlerweile ist ja die Clinton könnte krank zu heulen.
Es wird immer mehr als so ein Konjunktiv auch.
Clinton könnte krank sein.
Die könnte so krank sein, dass Michelle Obama den Platz einnimmt.
Stell dir mal das vor, dein ganzes Leben lang... Es wird immer mehr als so ein Konjunktiv auch. Clinton könnte krank sein, die könnte so krank sein, dass Michelle Obama den Platz einnimmt.
Stell dir mal das vor, dein ganzes Leben lang wirst du Präsidentin werden, dann bist du kurz davor und dann niest du einmal schlecht irgendwie und siehst aus wie ein fucking Alien und stolperst sich dagegen wie so ein Psycho.
Und dann kommt dein grüner Oktopus aus seinem Arm plötzlich raus.
Und dann plötzlich kommt der raus.
Mein Gott.
Und dann, ach jetzt, deswegen bin ich jetzt nicht Präsidentin, aber es war die vier Köpfe. Genau, das ist ja gar gar gar gar gar gar gar gar gar gar gar gar gar gar gar gar gar gar gar gar gar gar gar gar gar gar gar gar gar gar gar gar gar gar gar gar wie soll ich sagen, Papa, warum sind vier Eidechsen Präsidenten von den USA, wie konnte das passieren, und dann sage ich, ach, ich weiss es auch nicht, keine Ahnung. Ich Ich nehme auch oft so bei Verschwörungstheoretikern, ich verstehe woher das kommt, weil die Vorstellungen, die die vertreten, sind oft die coolere Welt. Chemtrails, wie cool wäre es bitte, wenn die Regierung uns mit Chemikalien vom Himmel irgendwie nürbemachen würde, wie cool wären Exenmenschen? Wie cool wären das denn bitte?
Man muss sich ja nur so Kristallstäbe in den Garten stecken und dann ist man ja gegen die Chemtrails geschützt. Das ist ja das eigentlich Geile, dass die nicht aufgeben, sondern dass sie sagen, ach, vielleicht helfen Kristalle. Oh, ich habe gar keine Atembeschwerden mehr, weil ich die eh nicht hatte und dann passt wieder alles. Das ist ja das Geile, dass du sagst, hier nimm diese Milchschnitte, die sind ja genauso positiv warm. Wie geil wäre eine Welt, in der uns die Regierung mit Nitroglycerin besprüht. Ja, aber können wir nicht einfach so grosse Triebwerke bauen, dass sich die Erde einfach in die andere Richtung mal dreht, für ein Jahr zumindest. Wie gut wäre das denn? Wie gut wäre es denn, wenn die Regierung das macht und ich mich schützen kann, indem ich einen Stab in den Rasen stecke. Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Das ist die perfekte Welt.
Ja, ich denke mir echt, gab es eigentlich in der Geschichte der Menschheit schon mal so einen wirklichen Politiker-Bluff, dass jemand gesagt hat, ich bin liberal, ich finde die Frauen gut, die Asylanten gut, und sobald er an der Macht war, nur noch Scheisse gebaut hat, gesagt, Fuck it, bin ich dich. Wir alle, 90% des Staatshaushalt, wir bauen jetzt einfach mal ein Seil, werfen wir bis zum Mond und wir hängen uns an diesen Mondtagen. Wir bauen eine riesen Hüpfburg, aber eine Stadtgrosse Hüpfburg. Ja, eine Hüpfstadt. Einfach weil wir es können. Einfach, fuck it. Hüpf doch. Ja, aber die Kinder sind krank. Ja, scheiss drauf. Die können hüpfen. Krank, aber hüpfen ist ja okay.
Sie können zur Schule hüpfen.
Gibt's doch eine Schule oder ist auch eine Riesenhüftburg.
Weiß ich nicht, weiß ich noch nicht.
Keine Ahnung, das klären wir dann.
Aber einfach mal ein paar Projekte umsetzen.
Wo soll's denn hin? Ja, neben Bällebadstadt.
Übrigens, wir bauen einen Riesen-Bällebad.
Ich meine, die Pyramiden waren eine Scheissidee.
Rückblickend, die waren scheisse.
Aber man könnte sie zu einem grossen Würfel zusammenstecken. Ja, aber das machen die Leute nicht, weil sie denken, oh, die Kinder sind immer noch krank. Und ich sage, jetzt hör doch mal auf, du diese scheiss hustende Kind aus meinem Gesicht, die ist mir doch egal, jetzt weg damit. So, aber weißt du, heute, man erinnert sich noch an die Pyramiden, aber dass damals hunderte Millionen Leute gestorben sind, interessiert keine Sau. Aber heute, ja, toller Sozialstaat, wow, in drei Jahren hat das kein Mensch vergessen. Ja, unseren tollen Sozialstaat hat man noch in vier Jahren vergessen, Demokratie geschenkt, in zehn Jahren interessiert das keinen mehr. Aber mal zu bauen, wir bauen irgendwie eine Kette und werfen die bis zum Saturn und hängen uns an den Saturn dran und schauen einfach mal, was passiert. Wie so ein Lasso. Ne, wie man sich mit so einem Skateboard an so ein Auto dranhängt. Wir hängen uns einfach mal an die Venus und lassen uns aus dem Sonnensystem zu katapulieren. Wir gucken mal, was passiert. Mentalität, die fehlt mir. Wir gucken mal, was passiert. Wir hängen uns an den Ring vom Saturn und schauen mal, wie weit wir den werfen können. Einfach mal gucken, ob wir den so zu uns ziehen können. Und dann gewinnen wir vielleicht aus Versehen, könnten wir ja so eine galaktische Olympiade gewinnen. Ja. Im Planetenring-Weitwurf. Vielleicht klappt das ja. Und dann plötzlich klappt das. Und dann kriegen wir so eine große Goldkette umgehangen, die ganze Erde, und die sackt erstmal so runter, ein paar Lichtjahre und so. Und dann kommt so ein galaktischer Riesenmann, der uns einen grünen Arm hinschreckt und uns k katholiert. Genau, und dann müssen wir so eine grosse Hand bauen aus Luftballons und Marshmallows, die dann die Hand schüttelt. Genau, und dabei noch das beste deutsche Lied. Ja. Wagner. Da, da, da, da, da, da. Und die Polen so, oh nein, nein, nein, nicht schon wieder. Dann lasst uns in Ruhe und dann, oh nee, jetzt kommen die Deppen wieder so. Und weißt du, und dann nächstes Jahr schauen wir wieder RTL 2, King of Queens. Was wir euch damit sagen wollten, ist für und ihn. Alter, ich habe so lange drauf gewartet, aber wollen wir es jetzt sagen? Ja. Wir haben einen Film gemacht. Dürfen wir das jetzt schon sagen eigentlich? Ich kann es gar nicht glauben, dass wir es schon sagen dürfen jetzt. Also tatsächlich dürfen wir es jetzt noch nicht sagen, aber in nächster Woche, wenn die Feuer rauskommt, dürfen wir es sagen. Und es ist kein Scheiss, es ist wirklich, wir sitzen hier seit, ich glaube, seit 10, 15 Folgen oder sowas. Wir haben schon mal zwischen dir was angekündigt, wir dürfen es nicht sagen. Es saßen wir hier und einmal mussten es rausschneiden, ich glaube, vor acht Folgen oder so haben wir gesagt, so ja, als wir gestern am Set waren oder so, mussten wir es rausschneiden. Aber wir mussten es wirklich verkneifen, auch die ganzen Moin Moins, wo ich irgendwie um Themen gerungen habe die ganze Zeit. Man sah dir an, dass du da irgendwie nicht so ganz auf dem Schirm warst. Ich musste mich so zusammenreißen, es nicht so auszuplaudern, aber jetzt dürfen wir es, und zwar haben wir einen Film gemacht. Ich habe einen Film mitgespielt, Regie geführt von Frederik Lau.
Krasser Typ.
Richtig krasser Typ, kennt man vielleicht aus Victoria. Und wir sind da echt mehr oder weniger durch Zufall reingekommen, halt irgendwie durch die BTF, wo wir gearbeitet haben. Ja, cooles neues Projekt, da hieß es mal irgendwann und haben uns für gemeldet. Und deswegen, viele haben sich gefragt, warum wir nicht mehr beim New Magazin im Abschnitt stehen und sowas. Und ja, wir haben einen Film gemacht. Und viel mehr kann man eigentlich noch nicht so essen. Es klingt so seltsam.
Es klingt so scheisse arrogant.
Ich dachte immer so, wie ist man dann? Weil irgendwann macht man halt einmal irgendwie sowas. Und dann sagt man halt so, ja, wir haben das gemacht. Und das ist jetzt raus in der Welt. Guck dich ihn an, geht in den Kinos. Im Kino halt, weißt du? Ich weiss nicht, wie oft ich... Ich habe wirklich, ich habe keine Ahnung, schon glaube ich 500 Filme im Kino gesehen. Und jedes Mal, ich schaue mir die Credits immer bis zum Schluss an und denke mir immer so, irgendwo ist er mein Name, irgendwo heisst vielleicht irgendwo mal ein Setdesigner, heisst vielleicht mal Florentin Wien, so im Kongolensischen, Keygrip, ja sowas, aber nie stand er da und jetzt halt irgendwie Premiere ist nächste Woche, gehen wir hin und sehen diesen Film und auf der Leinwand steht Stefan Hitzler. Nächste Woche schon? Nächste Woche in Berlin. Hast du einen Anzug rausgekramt? Ich habe noch keinen Anzug tatsächlich. Ich muss mir noch einen Anzug haben. Hast du einen Anzug, wollen wir zusammen einen Anzug geben? Ich hätte noch meinen Konformationsanzug, den nehme ich einfach. Na, los, habe ich bis jetzt immer genommen. Ne, wird nicht geil, guckt euch den Trailer an, wenn ihr ihn noch nicht gesehen habt. Gibt es auf ähm, weiß ich nicht, YouTube wahrscheinlich. Könnt ihr angucken. Könnt ihr angucken. Und wir sind, glaube ich, also ich bin mega stolz drauf und... Ich nicht so, ich finde das nicht so gut geworden. Das ist nicht so gut geworden. Ja, weil viele deine Ideen wurden ja in den letzten Minuten noch rausgeschnitten. Wir wurden alle rausgeschnitten, ich hätte keine machen. Leider, leider, leider. Schaut's euch an, schaut mal vorbei und ansonsten wünschen wir euch eine schöne Woche. Ich wünsche euch auch eine schöne Woche. Bleibt mal ein bisschen am Teppich. Falls ihr Ideen habt, welches Haustier sich Stefan Titzer als nächstes kaufen soll oder möchte, dann schreibt es einfach an florentin-at-will.org.
Und wir möchten die Frauen bestärken, alle Kommentare und alle Nachrichten, die wir von Frauen bekommen, nachweislich Frauen, zeigt ein Bild eurer Brüste, hängt es an, damit wir das verifizieren können, werden wir vorgelesen in HD.
Wir lesen sie von hinten nach vorne vor.
Bis dann, wünschen wir euch eine schöne Woche, macht's gut, bis dann und wir heben das nächste Mal ab, tschüss!